as night falls in Medellin a group of
teenagers ride their modified bikes down
these vertiginous roads the Crouch to
increase speed passing trucks and cars
at up to a hundred kilometers an hour
called gravity bikes they're Colombia's
more extreme version of an already
dangerous sport invented in the United
States and for many youngsters from poor
crime-ridden neighborhoods on the hills
around the city it has become a deadly
pastime seventeen-year-old marlon
lunatone is one of them you are always
thinking about the risks people crashing
getting killed and the serious accidents
we all suffer I know I need to think
chill out and understand I can kill
myself but we keep doing it because it's
our passion to go faster the bikes are
rebuilt often from scratch
riders personalize them and attach
weights to the frame to make them
heavier pedals and chains are removed to
reduce friction to get to the top of the
hills riders latch on to passing trucks
at times using homemade hooks on a line
Marlin has survived three close brushes
with death and proudly shows his cars
his friend Jota air tattooed on his
belly the name of a cousin who died in a
gravity bike accident
the town of Lusaka on the outskirts of
medellin has banned the practice
outright three of Marlins riding
companions have died this year alone and
serious accidents have become the norm
so much so that the school where most of
them study have started safety campaigns
and also donated helmets that nobody
really seems to be using the school
psychologist says most of the kids come
from broken homes and some fall into
drug abuse their bikes becoming a way of
demonstrating their value and courage do
you ask them they'll say they do it for
the adrenaline the desire to experiment
but the truth is they are often dealing
with depression parental absence so it
becomes a self-destructive way of
escaping from their reality nobody here
likes
to fall nor ruin the bike that was built
with so much sacrifice and time but it's
our lifestyle and we don't have any
other safer place to do it
Milan now understands he needs to take
more precautions but says he won't be
dissuaded Alison ramp et al Jazeera
Bogota